Phyllis I'm going to begin with you
because as I was getting ready for this
conversation one of the things I was
struck with was something that you said
about the whole process is that it was a
meditation on choice and both the
political
um the personal and everywhere in
between and I really appreciated that
because I think with stories like these
the Temptation or I should say the trip
would be to let the medicine mix too
much with the food to where you taste it
but this film really balances that in
such a great way and I know that was
from the intention from the beginning so
talk about how you balance the choice
with how you wanted to make it feel like
a cinematic's tale yeah thank you that's
a that's a great question and we all
talked about this a lot
um in the beginning with Robbie who sent
me the script
um I immediately saw that there was a a
way to make a film about a very serious
set of topics abortion women's rights
collectivism which is something dear to
me
um with a lightness of touch that would
hopefully speak to the widest possible
range of audience members
so we did set about to do that quite
purposefully
and in doing it I know that you enlisted
the incredible talents of these women in
front of me but before you even got
there it's it started with Ravi and and
the script and this journey and I do
have to say how did you sort of start
with that assembly like with with first
Phyllis but then more importantly the
ladies were about to speak to next it
started with really um Elizabeth
um who had read the script and I'm
friendly with her manager and she had
called me and said she responded to the
script and you should speak with her and
so Elizabeth and I spoke and I think we
saw eye to eye about you know what we
wanted to do in the story we wanted to
tell and we both thought it was very
important and
um and then ultimately uh Phyllis
um phyllis's agent called me and Phyllis
was passionate about the script and it
just so happens that Elizabeth and
Phyllis knew each other and it developed
a project in the past together so
serendipitously it all came together
they spoke and we decided to go on this
journey and that was probably three or
three or four years ago when covet
happened and but we managed to pull this
amazing cast together Sigourney and
Grace and woomi and
um I just feel so fortunate yeah to have
had just these strong powerful women
that were just very committed to making
this movie in very you know difficult uh
circumstances
Elizabeth have to bring it to you
because obviously I'm very familiar with
your acting work but also your work as a
producer and and especially just the
franchises that you have been a part of
and they are big and they are brow like
Rowdy I will love you for forever for
pitch perfect thank you very much but
with this one it is clear that this was
a project that not only were you
passionate about telling it not as a
woman but also I think as a producer to
say at the time when you started it this
was not the flash point that it is now
and don't you feel like girl like the
clock is is wrong at the wrong time but
it's also incredibly right that you have
essentially given this incredibly
cinematic
footnote for people to then be inspired
by to change looking back so how did
that work out the fact that when you
started this this was not after the
Dobbs decision and now about to go into
theaters it has really reframed it I of
course the timing is
um
I don't think there's a right word for
it you certainly wouldn't use
serendipitous that's terrible I think
you know I remember being told
um by men that I love
um don't be hysterical they're never
going to overturn Roe v Wade
so yeah
um I just feel like there was a uh when
I read this script I thought it was a
great Coming of Age story for a 40 year
old woman and a political Awakening for
somebody who was asleep in their life
somebody who never thought they would
have to seek abortion Health Care having
to do so and then really learning about
what that means for others who have to
walk that road and the Judgment that she
carried until she had to walk it and I
really felt like there was an
opportunity here to invite a lot of
people who could maybe relate to that
into the film and I had great Partners
the whole way who wanted it to be
she's named joy and I just remember
thinking like there has to be a sense of
effervescence in this there has to be a
sense of a woman making a life affirming
choice and
um an empowered choice and really taking
control over her life and I feel like
we've done it really beautifully in the
movie and
she can't do it without the help of
these other incredible women so the the
I I don't do anything on my own so I
really felt like the collective in it
was the collaborative in it the process
of making it it all came together yeah I
was just going to bring it there because
as much as Joy is a reluctant activist I
think no woman wants to be an activist
in this fight obviously but but joy in
particular in this really obviously
wrestles with the choice and then leans
into it heavily but to have the sort of
other side of that in these incredible
and fierce Warriors that have been in
the fight already played by you women
Sigourney it's just incredible to watch
and I have to say Mrs Sigourney Weaver
because I could never say your name to
your face like that otherwise
um but I have to say this I've watched
you fight aliens but watching you fight
this fight was probably the most
inspiring and terrifying thing I've ever
seen and it was such a joy to watch
so
how was that sort of again just shifting
it because it's so fierce but it is ever
flinching and I know that as we were
saying back there this was not you did
not want it to be as on time as it is as
prevalent as it is as timely as it is
when you set out to join this project
yes
um I felt very lucky to be asked to join
this Ensemble I loved Virginia she's so
out there and she's so direct and she's
so funny and
um I was alive
in uh during you know all the anti-war
protests for Vietnam and
you couldn't help noticing and it's true
in the films that have come out more
recently that women were sidelined and I
think that was very hard for Virginia
and I think when she found this
it became all important to her and her
joy in it
um and in helping women and The
Sisterhood
um
just gave her all the energy in the
world to keep doing this
um
so uh I I you know now is it even though
I was alive before Roe versus Wade was
passed there's such a big difference
which is that the women weren't
demonized the women weren't
criminalized for needing an abortion
um it's such a huge change from the way
things were
um and that breaks my heart and shocks
me to my core that this is this lack of
compassion lack of reality lack of
understanding and respect
for the Dignity of women is
just something that shocks me every day
since this happened and hopefully this
little film can
you know as Liz says invite people in
remind them perhaps of you know who's
really at risk here and
um
and hopefully within 18 days it will
make a difference at the polls woomi I
definitely want to speak to your
character in particular because I I will
go ahead and say it when I was watching
this at Sundance and I saw your
character come on I have to say in a
film like this as a black woman watching
you're like all right where are we going
with this look where are we going and I
was so so like relieved pleasantly
surprised and then eventually just
stunned by what this film does for you
and for that character and I I liked it
in particular by just how she did not
flinch with the inequity of of this
story and I know for you just the story
was shocking but was that shocking when
you saw how they treated the character
within this again very rich white female
world that she was navigating
um I don't think it was no I don't think
it was shocking
um because there has always been
uh
uh tension between the feminist movement
and the intersectionality of it and so
that
um
that combat we have I don't think it's
the only one we've had
and I think Gwen is just
so necessary in reminding
a room full of white women that there
were other people
that need them
um
so it wasn't it wasn't shocking it was
something that we really
um I guess the only shocking thing I
have is like the movie said it like I
know it happened but the movies don't
always say it like they Flinch away from
it yeah we we spoke about it a lot we we
all did actually because we felt like
this needed to be addressed that she's
the only black woman in the room
and how does she feel about it and what
is she going to do about it and what's
she gonna do with
these amazing women to make sure she's
not the only black woman in the room
um and she that
black and brown
low-income people
get the service and the help and The
Sisterhood that they need to
um yeah
I don't really need to add anything
other than it was fire
um um I will say this though too with
with Gwen and and with Virginia and with
all of these women is that they served
as an inspiration obviously because
their names and their and who they
represent are actually names that are
being echoed literally in the fight
today and Grace obviously your character
shows so much of that in in the time
frame but I have to think on set you're
not even thinking about that you're just
thinking about okay I got cast in a
movie with Ripley like this is this is
like the dream this is pretty dreamlike
for them just telling me to do this but
I do have to say so how how is that
because I cannot imagine I literally
cannot um even think about walking on
set that day
well actually Sig was very warm and
welcoming to me and becoming the
character and because she was alive in
that time and she had known women who
had gone through a similar thing
um we got to talk about how teenagers
back in that day were not really
involved in politics they were not
really uh welcome to speak about it or
learn about it they were kind of
expected to just go to school and be
children whereas now I think we we
involved them a little more and we want
to teach them more to become a powerful
adult and making their decisions
I wish we could speak for more time but
I want to thank the academy I want to
thank uh Roadshow attractions and I want
to thank all of you thank you so much
for for watching
here thank you